hello i'm zlatan i'm a third year
medical student studying at the
university of exeter and today i'm going
to share my study tips on how i ranked
first in my first year so i had the
highest end of year average amongst all
of my course mates
my first tip is planning planning
beforehand is very important because
when you put down every task that you
need to finish every topic that you need
to go through all the questions like how
many questions exactly in a very
detailed manner so you're more aware of
how much workload you have it will give
you a realistic idea of what you need to
do so that you can pass the exam seeing
all those tasks stuff that you need to
finish will stress you out a little bit
probably also it will push you you'll
actually realize the i guess seriousness
of the situation
so that you can study more and so that
you can plan your day ahead i usually
plan my day on the day because sometimes
life gets in the way if you plan your
whole month beforehand probably you
won't do the stuff that you've written
that day when the time comes because
there's always something that comes up
so my second tip is being comfortable
while you're studying being comfortable
really changes the game it lets you
enjoy the study process a lot more and
you can study for longer hours that way
if you're not comfortable in your seat
if you're in a really weird posture and
your back is hurting you're dehydrated
you're hungry the lighting is not great
the clothes that you're wearing are not
that comfortable then all i want to do
just jump to my bed and lie on my bed so
that my back can rest and i just want to
go on my phone so adjusting yourself
like trying to get to a comfortable
position rather than focusing on that
you want to focus on your work if for
example having a blanket around you
while you're studying is more
comfortable for you then do that as long
as it's not too comfortable that you
fall asleep most of the time i got my
blanket on if i'm studying in my room
bringing your laptop to your eye level
is also very helpful for the comfort of
your neck you can have some tea or water
with you basically whatever is going to
help with you feeling more cozy and
comfortable
using the same revision source is
important because it will help you
create a memory image for example a
specific powerpoint that your lecturer
has provided you on the notes that
you've found on the internet that you
found very helpful the next time you
revisit that topic go back to the same
revision source because whilst you
actually in an exam situation you're
trying to remember what was written in
that specific note that specific
information you're more likely to
remember you will be able to visualize
those notes that you went through
consistently rather than changing your
notes all the time because you revisited
that specific notes each time for you
more likely to remember the information
and so you're more likely to get the
answer right
my last step is not procrastinating and
actually get the work done if you like
to be on your phone via social media i
think phones are a big distractor for
that reason what i'd like to do before i
start my study session or study day i'd
like to put my phone on focus and
then put it in my wardrobe or somewhere
that i can't see my phone because even
seeing my phone can actually distract me
and also hearing those notifications can
be very distracting so just trying to
get rid of those distractors helps you
to sit down and get that work done and
procrastinate less
so thank you so much for watching this
video and if you found it helpful feel
free to subscribe and like this video
and if you want to know more about the
process that i went through to get into
medical school you can find that on my
channel as well thank you